[Music]
I'm a developer advocate at snake and
it's sneak we want to help you use open
source and stay secure and because we
eat breathe sleep security we've chosen
this intimidating-looking guard dog for
our logo but as a developer advocate
it's my job to be more like this golden
retriever friendly approachable helpful
really wanting to talk to you about open
source security so that's my goal right
and feel free to say hi on Twitter
because I'd love to chat open source
security with you so today we're gonna
do a few things first we're going to do
a very brief overview of serverless and
how it compares to some other solutions
you might have encountered then I'm
going to show you a demo app that I
built and then we're gonna hack it which
is my favorite part and finally I'm
going to give you a few takeaways so
when you go and build your serverless
app you have a few things to keep in
mind to help keep it secure alright so
when you're working with a cloud
provider like Google cloud platform
there's a few different ways that you
can organize your app and they're kind
of pros and cons to both or to any of
these and we'll kind of do a quick
overview of each so a monolith is what I
would kind of see as a more traditional
solution this is where your team handles
the virtual machines and your apps run
on that and you handle any or you handle
the operating system and the security
questions that arise within the
operating system so you have to make
sure that you stay patched so you're not
leaving yourself vulnerable and the
cloud platform very nicely handles your
hardware and it's just easier elasticity
and host setup ok this is working out so
with containers it's pretty similar
you your team's gonna handle your
virtual machines but within those
virtual machines you have containers and
those containers can have different
functionality in them and each container
can have its own operating system so
it's just a little bit more flexible and
you can spin up a new container if you
need it but you don't have to scale the
things you don't need and the cloud
platform it handles your hardware you
handle the operating system but it's
more flexible and this system is more
portable and it's easier elasticity and
host setup and finally you have what
we're gonna talk about today which is a
server list setup and in this kind of
situation you only really need to worry
about your app right so you worry about
your app and the functions inside of it
but the cloud platform handles your
virtual machine it handles your
operating system they handle the
hardware they you don't have to think
about operating system management the
hosts setup this is the best cloud
portability and has maximum elasticity
so this talk is about serverless
security and you may wonder well I have
given a lot of the security concerns
over to Google cloud platform and
they're doing a really good job with it
so what's left for me to secure and well
I I want you to think about your
application and this may be a broader
consideration then you may at first
think right this little chart here I
have the yellow represents the code that
you wrote but the code that you write is
not the entirety of the code that you
ship okay
the big blue circle represents the code
that you ship and the part that isn't
the little yellow dot well those are
your dependencies so let's take an
example in one of sneek serverless
demo apps we have 222 lines of code and
that's you know that's really trim
not much not much to survey and you know
you could you could look and find
security problems pretty quick but in
addition we have five direct
dependencies and because those
dependencies have dependencies we have
54 total dependencies and you can write
shrug at this but it actually adds up to
nearly half a million lines of code
which is a lot right and how many
security vulnerabilities are within
those half a million lines of code all
right so Google cloud platform is going
to secure the operating system for your
surveillance app but you need to
consider your application security you
need to consider all of it not just the
yellow dot so let's take a look at my
sample app and we're going to hack it
all right because I like a bit of whimsy
in my life the sample app is a to-do
list abstence ibly written by my cat to
make sure that I do all the things that
he requires okay and I have a function
within this app that renders the to-do
list really nicely so you can see we
have the start of that to-do list here
and if I wanted to add to this to-do
list I can hit the HTTP point with a
simple curl command we already have feed
cat on the list so we're gonna say feed
cat again because that's just how it's
just how it works
and so we see that a an item was created
and when i refresh this it's going to
show the new task right and this is
awesome
Jacques he's gonna add as many things as
he wants to right but maybe I don't like
that so much you know I'm the boss he's
not the boss right so what would happen
if I want to take this app down to cut
it off at its knees and I'm gonna show
you how we might do that so first off
I'm gonna show you sneaks website where
I've uploaded this app it looks at the
dependencies within the app and it scans
them and it lets me know when there are
known vulnerabilities so within my
dependencies there are actually nine
known vulnerabilities there may be more
but these are the ones we know about
their they have CVEs all those different
things and some of them we can exploit
and get in so the one we're going to
look at is a regular expression denial
of service so this vulnerable module ms
it's it's in our app because it helps us
parse time fields kind of so to give you
an example of that let's say my cat
really wanted to take a nap but he
wanted to be woken up so he's gonna add
an item to the to-do list of wake cat in
two days so he's going to take a nice
long nap
and so we do another curl commands and
it creates another item on our list and
we can see it here weight capped and it
recognized two days as time period and
so that's why you see that formatting
there right and we could build
functionality around that to like send
out our reminder or something along
those lines right however I'm kind of
fed up with this whole thing and I'm
going to create or try to create a
command or a to-do item that it's going
to take the system too long to do
matching right so if I have a let's see
so I'm going to use this curl command
which tries to add a to-do item to
provide snacks in an amount of time
that's really long and just to keep it
chugging away and trying to figure out
what's going on a little bit longer I
misspelled minutes okay
says here minute T so let's see what
happens then well nothing right it's
still chugging along trying to make a
match somewhere and trying to do its
regular expression thing right but while
it's running like this my cats whether
he wants to or not
he can't add any new two deuce to my
to-do app and so I really appreciate
that and I'm just really glad I was able
to stop him in his tracks just using
this simple regular expression right so
I'm gonna just kill this so once again
I'm the master not Jacques so let's go
back to the presentation
so I have a few takeaways that hopefully
you can use when you're writing your
next server list app and briefly there
too number one
beware vulnerable libraries number to
deploy granular functions and
permissions number three don't rely on
function ordering number four don't rely
on immutability and number five to worry
about all functions so first off
beware vulnerable libraries test during
development and monitor over time this
is exactly the kind of problem that I
just took advantage of when I broke
Jaques to-do list right and here's a
little snippet of the snake website and
you can see that it'll list out the
vulnerabilities and give you a little
report about them and so then you know
and it also will tell you what
remediation can be taken right so this
is a very important thing to be aware of
secondly you should deploy granular
functions and permissions it's safer so
think about today you were able to come
down into this space because you have a
badge I'm looking out and you all have
badges on right but your badge doesn't
get you just or it doesn't get you into
the entirety of this space right there
are doors and things that you need a
special badge for or a different colored
badge you know something along those
lines
it would be madness to issue everyone
that came to Google cloud next just a
generic like you're allowed everywhere
badge right and it's the same here to
plug granular functions and permissions
don't let everyone access every function
it's just better all right
don't rely on function or during every
function is a perimeter that needs to be
secured and when I think about this one
I think about how I don't not lock my
safe just because I've locked my door
right
don't rely on these initial functions to
protect the ones that are maybe further
in your app right every function is a
prim has a perimeter that needs to be
secured forth
don't rely on immutability assumed
servers can be reused and just in
general assume don't don't make
assumptions that could compromise your
security right and finally worry about
all functions every function increases
your attack surface let's say you have a
house that has 10 windows and you were
very diligent and you alarmed and locked
eight of them but two of them are open
or maybe they're not open but they're
just not locked well if you have
something of value in your home the
eight highly secured windows aren't
going to deter someone who wants to
break in to get what you have right so
it doesn't matter that you've secured
those eight what matters is that there's
a way in in those two windows so finally
just one more quick review beware
vulnerable libraries deploy granular
functions and permissions
don't rely on function ordering don't
rely on immutability and worry about all
functions also don't let your cat boss
you around so thank you all again I'm
Haley Dunn braver I'm a developer
advocate at sneaked feel free to say hi
on Twitter at Haley Dunn be or to follow
my company sneak at SN y KS EC or to
check out our website on sneak IO you
can try the tools that I showed you for
free and yeah thank you all for being so
great
[Music]